on va voir parce qu'il ya une histoire
qui pourrait être un canular est-ce de
l'info est de l'intox
le 7 mars 1984 le services des égouts de
la ville de paris lance un appel
d'urgence à la caserne des pompiers du
1er arrondissement un animal suspect a
été repéré à deux reprises dans les
égouts situé sous la rue du pont neuf
il s'agit peut-être d'un crocodile
nous sommes partis après une première
recherche qui s'est révélé pratiquement
infructueux nous avons approfondi
quelque peu hélas un crocodile de 70 à
80 centimètres environ a été trouvé dans
lego nous avons pris une pelle à balai
et nous avons essayé de stopper sa
progression
ce que nous avons réussi à faire et puis
nous lui avons fille stella gueule de
façon à ce qu'ils ne nous passe pas le
crocodile est aussitôt transférés à la
ménagerie du jardin des plantes pour
être examiné c'est un crocodile du nil
et il est en parfaite santé
c'est quand même assez possible ce qui
fait relativement chaud dans les égouts
qui a de l'eau par définition et qui à
la nourriture en tout cas pour des
crocodiles des proies vivantes des rats
très probablement des tas de nourriture
de viande même un peu avariée or les
prédateurs on le sait sont relativement
robuste aux infections et résistant et
donc il a très bien pu survivre un mois
un mois et demi deux mois dans les
égouts nous on l'a gardé un petit moment
ici dans cette cage là où il ya
maintenant le bois et on était vite
confronté à un problème de place parce
qu'il a grandi quand même et nous avons
été obligés de le mettre en dépôt dans
un dans une autre institution dans un
aquarium en province pour qu'ils aient
une place suffisante pour continuer de
grandir
c'est à l'aquarium de vannes que nous
l'avons enfin retrouvé dans un terrarium
spécialement construit pour lui le
crocodile breton a aujourd'hui une
dizaine d'années il est en pleine
croissance et n'a toujours mangé
personne
c'est une espèce qui est agressive qui
est potentiellement dangereuse pour
l'homme c'est un animal qui dans la
nature atteint une taille de 4 à 6 m
personne ne l ayant réclamé
on pense que c'est une personne qui
devait l'avoir chez elle certainement
dans une baignoire est arrivé à une
certaine taille et ils ont pu s'en
débarrasser
ce ne sont pas des animaux de compagnie
aujourd'hui notre crocodile passe sa vie
à lézarder peut être
regrette-t-il la vie trépidante du pari
underground un proc de trouver dans les
égouts de paris s de l'info ou de
l'intox
vous n'en savez rien jacques dutronc le
sait peut-être en écoute à l'oreille
très bien